[Musique]
non non ce n'est pas du tout pour mettre
un mur entre les gens et moi moi j'aime
beaucoup les gens c c'est un goût très
simple je crois simplement le goût des
des arbres de la nature de la terre et
puis surtout aussi pour fuir je crois
l'agitation des villes qui est de plus
en plus affolants moi je ne peux pas
entendre le bruit
j'aime le calme j'aime me réveiller le
matin dans un jardin alors je crois que
c'est un goût extrêmement peu plus
compliqué que ça mais beaucoup de gens
qui ne peuvent pas s'asseoir et vous
avez toujours été comme ça non parce que
je ne pensais même pas que c'était
possible enfin quand j'étais très jeune
j'aimais beaucoup la campagne ça il y
aller il faut de temps en temps mais je
ne m'imaginais pas que c'était possible
de vivre la campagne de travailler paris
d'une période d'adaptation au début au
loin qu'on arrive à pas le soir on se
dit mon dieu ma voiture et là on va
quand même à paris oui d'ailleurs
j'habitais rue des jeux vidéos plus près
de paris quand j'ai commencé à habiter
la campagne et puis way et puis même
n'est qu'après je suis allez encore un
petit peu plus loin parce que je
trouvais trop près de paris la prochaine
étape sera la prochaine étape
enfin je ne sais pas donc en même temps
du tournoi je trouve que j'ai beaucoup
de mérite
justement agi avec cette discrétion
parce que vous êtes ce qu'on appelle
veulent être consacrés vous savez ce que
suppose ce thème en fait non les gens ne
suppose pas toujours en quoi consiste le
fait d'être une vedette est ce que vous
pouvez par exemple choisir vos films
imposer les sujets aux nous ne
marquerons été refusée les sujets qui ne
me plaisent pas un sujet pour à leur
fusée c'est un sommet lorsque
il n'en est jamais arrivé de lire un
livre de dire c'est ça que je veux
tourner et de voir ce livre porté avec
rome c'est arrivé une fois quand j'étais
très jeune j'avais une envie folle je ne
pensais qu'à ça de tourner la renarde
mais web et je crois que c'est la seule
fois de ma vie où j'ai eu vraiment envie
de tourner mais je n'ai pas tourné dès
hier alors j'ai après je me suis dit
qu'il valait mieux pas s'attacher comme
ça jusqu'à l'âge précis de vente
oui on risque d'être déçu on on ne peut
pas toujours faire ce qu'on veut et nous
sommes avec vous quand ça ne marche pas
tout de suite aux conseils que je ne
peux jamais marcher et que commencer
c'est à dire que s'il quand vous
reprenez quelque chose et que vous
sentez pas succès au bout de cette
aventure vous abandonner complètement
ah oui moi je crois que les choses se
font je crois beaucoup à la destinée
d'une clause qui sont l'essence en pro
forcé jeux franco hasard il ya quelque
chose d'étrange en tout cas d'un dans
votre destinée l'actrice sait que en ce
moment personne n'écrit de mal de vous
dans les jours donc c'est extrêmement
rare on dit quelquefois du mal des films
dans lesquels vous êtes que les écrits
qui m'est impossible pas toujours mais
vous maintenant on en dit plus de mal
face à vous me l'apprenez d'abord parce
que je ne nie pas les jeux d'eau enfin
un peu de journaux ici et puis un jour
moi je fais des films on pourrait me
dire du mal de moi aussi tout mais au
nom de la toiture
on n'en dit pas la remarquer que c'est
d'une façon d'autant plus sympathique on
nous appelle pas encore grande dame du
cinéma 59 une actrice grand dam de la
masse toujours un peu grave
non non on n'en est pas là mais tout le
monde dit du bien de vous est-ce que ça
a toujours été comme ça nous ont bien
sûr quand j'étais jeune
j'avais terrain devant la presse oui
vous vous dites est charmante petite
jeune fille qu'est ce qu'on disait tout
vous jouiez mal que vous n'aviez aucun
avenir
exactement j'essaye de mettre du baume
dans le coeur je sois vraiment le géant
des pâtes comédienne que j'étais le
genre je sais pas moi ce qu'on dit un
petit peu des rescapés de la binette
enfin mais avant la guerre c'était sa
vie avait d'autres termes se ressemblent
en france leurs congés payés légèrement
qui n'était pas vraiment capable de
tenir des rôles
si par exemple je vais vous poser une
question classique parce qu'il n'y a pas
de raison que le fasse aujourd'hui tour
d'acrobaties pour ne pas poser de
questions habituelles on ne sait pas si
par exemple vous le demander dans quel
film
vous avez l'impression que vous
ressemblez plus ça vous avez tourné aura
aucun vous n'êtes jamais retrouver tel
que vous êtes dans un film
non je crois non c'est toujours très
différents vous ne pensez jamais tourné
un rôle de femme très simple à l'accord
en font ou disent que je suis fière
nous sommes c'est cela que vous chercher
maintenant non non non ce serait très
désagréable je crois de tournai
s'approprier de sa propre vie et son
propre caractère
je sais beaucoup plus amusant de de
tourner d'autres d'autres caractères
enfin très différente soit c'est ça qui
est amusant souhaitiez
[Musique]